cela pourrait-il être après toutes ces années et je
sais que vous n'oubliez jamais une chose que je
voulais introduire dans ce film est le hoquet
découvre qu'il y a ce mystérieux
justicier qui est en fait sa mère
Valka a été prise par un dragon alors qu'il n'était
qu'un bébé dans  le berceau ce n'est pas tous les
jours que tu découvres que ta mère est une
sorte de dame folle de dragon sauvage
j'ai écrit le personnage avec Cate
Blanchett à l'esprit elle était un
modèle parfait pour le mauvais personnage
Dean je déteste je n'ai pas encore les mots
pour voir  ce magnifique sanctuaire où
elle a sauvé tous les dragons sur lesquels elle pouvait mettre
la main sur lui j'ai cru être l'un d'
eux pendant 20 ans mais de deux manières en
découvrant leurs secrets il les aime
sa connaissance des dragons est si profonde et
son lien avec eux son peuple  à son
propre puits cette fois que vous avez pris après que j'ai
renoué avec sa mère, il commence
à mieux comprendre ses
liens avec le cœur des dragons, vous savez
que cela ne s'efface pas et je suis pour mon père
pour stoïque, il se reconnecte avec salut  l'
amour perdu depuis longtemps qu'il pensait être parti
pour toujours est beau comme le jour où je t'ai perdu
c'est une chance c'est quelque chose que je n'aurais
jamais pensé être plus possible
qui est d'avoir ma femme à vélo pour passer une
fête des mères et j'ai une famille  encore une fois
reviendrez-vous à la maison que voyez-vous et
ensuite nous les verrons tous les
trois affronter l'ennemi commun drago
bludvist moi seul absous les dragons
Donald a cette armée de dragons et ils
veulent conquérir le contrôle du monde
Valka a des milliers de dragons
qu'elle a été sauvée des pièges de Drago Van
Exel
quelle équipe maintenant que voulez-vous
faire nous avons ce drame de reconnexion familiale en
toile de fond assez
heureux quelle est votre mère welp maintenant vous
savez où j'obtiens mon flair dramatique
vous êtes plus proche que vous  jamais pensé
possible cela semble incroyable
chaque dragon a ses secrets le saviez-vous